[Music]
Kim and Kanye are filled with so much
happiness following the birth of their
fourth child it definitely opened up my
eyes to a whole different world a source
tells et that the couple feels complete
with the addition of their newest son
adding that Kim has always wanted a big
family having kids is just there's no
way to describe it the source goes on to
explain that Kim and Kanye are enjoying
this moment as a family and are taking
the time to fully embrace each new
moment that comes with this new chapter
I love that on Friday the reality star
announced that she and Kanye had
welcomed a baby boy via a surrogate
tweeting he's here and he's perfect in a
second tweet Kim wrote
he's also Chicago's twin lol I'm sure he
will change a lot but now he looks just
like her baby boy West Whedon at 6
pounds 9 ounces
according to Kim's rep both she and
Kanye were present for his birth and
according to a previous source the new
parents of 4 are over the moon with
excitement I mean I think everything and
life happens for a reason of course the
latest Kardashian West babe joined
siblings 5-year old North three-year-old
st. and one-year-old Chicago who was
also born through surrogacy anyone that
says or thinks it's just the easy way
out is completely wrong yeah I think
it's so much harder to go through it
this way cuz you're not really in
control I hated being pregnant and I
never thought I'd ever I thought this
was gonna be so easy and you know but I
still even in how much I hated it if I
could do it myself I would have
preferred that so that's a little like
that inner struggle is kind of hard but
I'm just rolling with it and it is what
it is last time we sat down you had
mentioned that the thing that really
stressed you out about surrogacy
like the lack of control because you are
such a boss and you're in control is it
different this time
um it's a different experience for sure
I think every situation is different I
love my surrogate we have a really good
relationship I know that she I really
trust her and I definitely see like the
first time that I went through it I was
a little bit more anxious yeah you know
maybe texting more and calling more and
I feel like my surrogate this time
around really is such a protecting
person and I really trust that in her so
I feel really calm and at ease I don't
know if it's like a fourth kid thing
right or just we've been through the
surrogacy thing before you just get a
little bit more calm as as they go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]